[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings and
tributes are pouring in for former
secretary of state madeleine albright
today she died yesterday
she was a trailblazer and a leader in
the fight for human rights and democracy
albright as you know made history back
in 1997 as the first female secretary of
state and at the time think about this
she was the highest ranking woman in the
history of the u.s government wow
it was president bill clinton who
nominated her for the job but they were
also friends for decades their former
president joins us now on the phone good
morning to you mr president
good morning y'all how are you
i'm okay i'm okay we really wanted to
see you this morning but we're glad to
have your voice here this is what you
said what what you once said about
madeleine albright few leaders are so
perfectly suited for times in which they
serve what made her so special and how
are you remembering her today
well first of all
i'm remembering her as a great friend of
hillary and me for many many years we
just loved her and
she was a special woman but she was
suited for the time because
it was keep in mind it was
the end of the cold war i was the first
president to serve my entire tenure
after the fall of the berlin wall and
the
disillusion of the soviet union so we
all had to decide what to do and we were
trying to build a world
and particularly a europe
that was democratic
at peace
working together for shared prosperity
for the first time since
nations that existed on the european
continent and
madeleine was perfect because
her family was run out of czechoslovakia
twice
first by
hitler and then by stalin
and she
did not like
authoritarian governments she didn't
like dictators she didn't like
people who were callous about human life
and
it forged her whole
view of the world for the rest of her
life i mean it was
she was perfect to serve at a time
when we were trying to build a new
future
and also
trying to guard against to return to an
ugly past
i know that you spoke to her great
mr president i know you spoke to her
two weeks ago
i'm wondering how what was she what was
she feeling how was she thinking was she
thinking the end was near or was she
still talking about current events
what's going on in the world today
i think she knew that she might not have
long to live because she'd been
battling an illness but it was very
interesting her attitude was
look um
i've got a good doctor and i'm getting
treatment and what's going to happen is
going to happen what we should be
thinking about
is the world we'd like to leave to our
grandchildren
and she spent the whole rest of the time
talking about
ukraine and
it was like the replay of a bad movie
for her
as well as a very modern tragedy and
and it confirmed to her that we did the
right thing
to expand nato
and
we understood that all those countries
that near
live near russia
they were hoping that they'd have good
relations with russia and many did for
many years
but they were also planning for the
worst
and they they did not want to be
at the mercy of what russia decided to
do
when the leader got up one morning and
madeleine had been worried about it for
years and she wrote
a great book
about
dictators
kind of an anti-fascist book
and
she knew
and
it was we had a wonderful talk she said
you know we just
think about how awful it will be
if our grandchildren can't
think about what america was for me
yeah at one point she said vladimir
putin was is very smart but a very bad
person
he's very what
she said he's smart but a very bad
person yeah
yeah she always thought that
but
she thought that as soon as he played
his hand we
you know we worked with him for 10
months
in the first 10 months of his
term
and he was reasonable more or less in
his first
go around as president and you know he's
on his third go around he got
progressively worse
and he
in terms of being
more dictatorial
more aggressive
and
more determined to use
cyber attacks and other things
to divide and weaken america
his presence the whole goal was to
divide and weaken america and other
countries in his neighborhood and then
he wanted to gobble up ukraine
mr president this is vlad let me ask you
about that specifically as it relates to
ukraine yesterday the president of the
republic of kosovo yososmani tweeted
this
kosovo lost an invaluable friend he also
went on to say 23 years ago nato
intervened to stop ongoing genocide
against the people of kosovo you
absolutely remember those days given
that the united states now says that
vladimir putin is committing war crimes
in ukraine should the united states do
more to help the ukrainian people
well i think that
that's exactly what
president biden's and europe to discuss
with them
about how to maintain
unity in europe
keep in mind i tried for
two and a half years
to get everybody uh
agreed to take more aggressive action to
stop
the ethnic cleansing in bosnia
and it wasn't until the slaughter of
srebrenica in 1995
that
europe and nato flipped
that is i had to you know get all of our
allies there and we
and he's got a lot more members of nato
now that
they're trying to hold together and i i
i'm sure
that that's one thing they're discussing
that is
you know they want to get more weapons
into those countries
and they want to get more
humanitarian supplies
and they're working on that but i think
this is certainly a case
when the united states can have only one
president at a time but
i will support whatever they decide to
do
to try to make sure ukane survives and
eventually prevails they are doing their
part and then some they have been so
brave
and
they have
you know everybody just assumed they
would fold
as soon as
putin started hitting them and he's
been more ruthless more quickly than i
thought
but they have fought as soldiers well on
the ground
and
if ever there was an example of a
country that wants to be free and
independent
it's ukraine
putin kept you know talking about how
they really were a creation of mother
russia and they were just coming home
and
he accused them of being pro-nazi when
today
when they've got a
jewish president who's
five foot four i think but a giant in
his strength
so that's what the president's doing and
i'm gonna i think
you know as long as we're all together
with nato and all together with europe
i think we should
you know encourage them and support them
but we need as little second guessing as
possible now
mr president um madeleine albright once
said it took me quite a long time to
develop a voice now that i have it i'm
not going to be silent what comes to
mind is president zielinski he has been
very vocal about how he and the
ukrainian people will not back down what
is your impression of his leadership
during these times
he's been amazing
uh he's been
resolute and
he's been energetic and he's been
sort of
upbeat in the but a brutally brutally
honest about what they're facing
so
you know you can
it's a very difficult time for people
who are pulling for ukraine because
you read
about all this suffering and all these
people that
have been killed by the indiscriminate
bombing
to which
the russians have resorted
when putin
didn't get them to roll over and
you know just become a
another province of russia i mean he
basically
thought that once he roughed him up a
little bit they would fold and instead
they said thank you very much we like
our freedom we like our democracy
and i know a lot of people are involved
mr president a lot of people are on all
the ukrainian people we have dentists
and grocery workers who have never
picked up a gun who are now out there
fighting for their lives in their
country
please give your best give our best to
your wife that would be hillary clinton
she was tested positive is she okay
she's doing fine you know we uh
she's
we've been more interested in
ukraine and madeleine albright and we
yeah then we have in
her
infection because she's
it just made her tired but she
was fully vaccinated had her booster
and she was she got a little tired and
then she's going all right we're going
to be fine
i just hope that the ukrainians will be
fine
yes a lot of people feel that thank you
very much for your time this morning and
our best to me thank you so much
you're welcome